welcome to this video playing my way
from Norway yeah and let's see we played
some of those advanced variations they
should be five he played H for them yeah
okay let's try the c5 line this is what
I had recommended in my in my series on
the ICC Queens your phone can I really
forgot Allah all I all I recommended hmm
Quincy form cannot play move like f6 or
is this completely ridiculous hmm Bishop
f4 you can maybe just cover it and what
am I playing after Bishop f4 not clear
f5 f5 look stupid
hmm yeah okay if you really should know
the opening if you play such a sharp
line I mean if I did this video series
for for the SSC but I really forgot my
own recommendation here 24 it's a very
rare move and probably not not a great
one but so I don't remember what then
what you are supposed to play yeah it
should f for him I guess you have tween
80 593 maybe just here covering 37
attacking c5 maybe I can just take c5
Bishop to ship to a forum if I play if I
play can i play at five and then take c5
and it's probably not not great but at
least it it's even material if sometimes
you need to be a content with little
things
hmm I wonder what he's thinking about
Queen g3 looks som like the the normal
move maybe I'm a between 83 with a bit G
for coming he's an interesting and
aggressive player maybe he's no it's not
going for that ok I want to want to have
it back but Queen 85 was also an idea
but I didn't think it is too great now
it is threatening winning a piece but ok
he attended to that so what now how do i
get get developed nice to his heaven
blunders the jeep on
night h6 is also not great yeah I move
like age 65 is probably completely
you're taken okay come on I need to be
here it's of course a bit like asking
for it g5 mmm how bad is g5 now probably
it is not enough compensation but okay I
need to get them get my stuff out here
somehow I want to get the Queen over and
play Bishop d7 long castles probably 95
s sir is the right none right move now
probably because it covers h7 okay
really okay let's go here and see what
he's doing okay i'm not thinking that
i'm winning here or anything but the
other other moves look too much much
easier
so let's zoom or 97 prom and I know I'd
like to play 95 of course but the hand
pinch yeah this looks like a good
position offer black I mean I just have
an attacker long castles hook g8 look
sir looks great 95 is a real threat now
maybe I could have played this actually
the stead of this should be six routine
with 95 yeah 95 and curtains isn't it I
can take this happen and this is a check
you're still it looks terrible it should
be 797 k + 85 bishops is having us not
helping wide I came so
yes I don't think he can take with any
peace now it's everything is tied
always mates on h 2 h 1 and so on and
now i'm covering you five I can can I
just take it I don't want to this
threatens on edge to this is I think
this is strong
let's take this piece yeah it says this
not this is not a big threat or anything
I have c7 covered okay
can just take it now everything time
morning
yeah not the best moves but sufficient
oops yeah III was was a blonde I can
take back okay I'm two pieces up can
even blunder one back end doesn't matter
good game thanks he is always sometimes
writing something frankly yeah this was
a was a very complicated game and I'm
pretty sure I'm bed in this opening here
something went wrong but this is not not
so easy I mean maybe I'm just he can
just win outright with something that I
don't see but I think it just he needs
to take with the night this is the
problem if he if he takes with the night
I cannot go queen age 7 here they cannot
cannot go here obviously and after this
um oops after the night takes I thought
maybe Queen g7 or something just even
working Quincy three oops yeah on night
night here to here I don't know it's not
not great but I wanted to do something
and okay Queen takes Queen age seven now
is tricky this this is a big threat and
here computer once to play Bishop deform
yeah computer style and here i can take
only five maybe I didn't take that into
account but it's not so clear I can take
now here I don't want to give the bishop
this is
the bishop is a strong piece okay this
was good after all and maybe if a 4 s
really a bit slow and this is leaving
the best move long castles is winning
instantly according to comp now probably
yeah yeah yeah the problem is that now
I'm threatening to take here and i can
actually recapture with the rook so
let's say makes nothing then i can can
take here jack now take with this and
this this is now completely overloading
white he will leave lose the house now
yeah this was very nice this can spray
me not not entirely clear in five yeah
maybe you can in computer wants to go in
for but i'm not the comp so b6 and now
if i am this this is I didn't see so
much wider than blocking I can take here
and this is actually still a still a
game here you will get the Queen back
and can still fight it's better for
black but ok but this is just better
there's no move now hangs hangs and snow
move nice center yeah thanks for
watching interesting game